[музика]
у кафе на раю
дрінь-дри
дві
одна секунда і стоп година вийшла у все
чи бачиш вигляд чи
Світлана
[музика]
значить
Мемо доступ до
гріховних сайтів та до розпустних
Я поважаю плюс
Охеріти я просто в шоці
200 гривень комуналка вийшла Нормально
Нормально млинець взагалі
[музика]
Що за [ __ ] за графіком ще не відомо
буде
[музика]
поки 4 роки найматися зуби світло без
нічого все ось так і все давлюсь у стіну
[музика]
[оплески]
з Путіним
[музика]
Русь не [ __ ]
у нас
[музика]
тут Синема я куплю собі вітру до скоро
вже зима зима вже близько
Скоро зима
зима
так і капелюх вилути і ви я була базу
нашої біологічності брови ось ці голуби
дрони на піцу щоразу покажу нас
Правда Через цілих
комплектована все стояти сильно
зарядишся Ось
[музика]
[оплески]
ми виходить
[музика]
йому зараз провини Макдональдс поспішаю вибух.
KFC завищилось
бо полковник
[музика]
[сміх]
і вночі
[музика]
тепер необхідно схрестити
схрестив
тепер кінець шнурка знизу просунь ось
це дірку так званого Затягні
шоу Танці з полонез ми знаємо
наші місця
[оплески]
[музика]
з Петербурга вилітає
нашої програми
[музика]
коротше видно як пожила тут лише
Україна і знову скінчується тим, що не
буде знову від тих хто сказав та їх не
України
[музика]
у них показує унітаз біля унітазу
котячий якийсь туалет але мало того що
унітази у всіх і кухня Прикинь заходить
кухні відразу ну це гаразд і в туалеті
Подивися скільки
вони спеціально почекай у чому прикол
спеціально купують якесь фігню
туалет котячий не пісок просто і не
ганчірочку кладе А у них така скринька і
там якась
спеціально витрачати гроші на кішок
це
Я не знаю маразм
тому що розумію, що ці західні
технології Так ось коли-небудь корм для
котів
Який корм для котів що жеремо Ми теж
подивіться як і консерви як для людей
я тобі відповідаю
смерть катан
взагалі ось ці українці Вони ненавидять
ненавидять Якого вони кажуть смерть
котам розумієш котам вони Постійно
кажуть сміти кататися
[музика]
диво
ви чули що ось ці ось зараз
українці проти наших спецпідрозділів
елітного спецрозділу Кадиров Вони ж
знають що мусульмани сало не їдять вони
беруть усі міни всі кулі натирають сало
спеціально щоб потрапляли куля ви
кадировця щоб він до раю не потрапив
[музика]